they're a genuine questions here aren't
there about false narrative narrative
that were put out not least by the
police but also by newspapers like
they're not not entirely just the son
but primarily by the Sun newspaper at
the time and that compounded the hurt of
these families who lost 96 Astoria unity
lost 96 every time it comes up again
every time it's talked about every
single person he works on the Sun
shudders with horror and embarrassment
because without a single shadow of a
doubt it was the worst thing we ever did
at a newspaper it was asked worst day
our deepest shame and it continues and
it is embarrassing to be remembered when
I'm sitting here squirming as you can
tell and rightfully so because our front
page of the truth famously a few days
after Hillsborough was I think we
haven't their apologies so we have
apologized in the past we continue to
apologize remember when the the great
report that uncommon all the police
cover-ups fusing in 2013 came out 2012
2012 a cap on we had a banner massive
front page saying the real truth we got
it wrong
the police lied we lied to you or we
misled you because we didn't know it was
a lie the time and you know we keep on
us I can tell you that tomorrow we are
also apologizing again you know just
seems a shame that you've not taken the
chance to do it on the front page and
there's a whatsapp story and I think you
can you know discuss at a tour of
judgments about what should or should be
on the front page but in our paper
tomorrow there are two extremely large
pages of a very significant coverage
which talk about the huge importance of
this day for the people who've suffered
for the families who've spent so long
trying to you know write her wrong and
even lives yet another sorry no I
probably from the Sun I don't think we
should all be about the Sun it was not
us that committed Hills ripples and I
slit you know the problem with this
venture is little easy just to go back
to that to original front-page some
trans work America sockets to victims
sometimes this I know this came from the
police that that that's the theory
anyway sometimes pick the pockets of
victims sometimes urinated on the brave
cops
some fans beat up a PC giving the kiss
of life there was talk of a young female
victims top had gone up and some abuse
about her all on the front page just
four days after people died
for days and I know you might blame
Kevin with your fish or more I can say I
mean the papers apologize five or six
times it was the worst possible thing we
could ever have done and we did it and
you know we're apologizing a narrative
that came and paper in coverage like
that and what we heard from the police
the cover-up that we will talk about in
a moment that's why it's taken 27 years
to get to today imagine what I would say
is that we have apologized for this a
long time before the police of them the
Police Federation weren't even
apologizing today you know they're man
up in Yorkshire was saying it was not
for me to talk about topic we've done
look it is also a testament to how
powerful the Sun is as a communicator in
this country so you've huge cultural
bond it's the biggest newspaper it's so
influential it sets the tone for how
people have seen this story over the
last quarter of a decade and again I
know this is the last time I will bang
on the bat I promise it's just that look
when the Sun gets the front the Sun
sometimes can brilliantly capture the
mood of where the public is and I think
it would have done itself a huge it
wouldn't have completely right as if it
would if it would have sent a very
powerful message that you guys cannot
seesaw enough and I don't at all doubt
your sincerity Tom I think you are
genuinely squirming I can see it in your
sadness in your eyes he wants to move on
yeah I'm just gonna show you the Metro
which is a parody is that original paper
as you can see and the world will really
ask people if you're still angry with
the Sun I can completely understand it
you know we deserve everything that's
thrown away quite frankly but please
remember the 2012 front-page that we ran
saying the real truth we got it wrong we
could not have done anything worse and
we're profoundly sorry and yet again we
repeat this apology in our paper
tomorrow yeah